I was thinking about how much my little
brother
Adam and my dad do for me
and actually now that I think about it
Austin my other brother
also really helped me when I was in
Milwaukee because I used to live in
Milwaukee for a little bit and so did he
like
he would help me move all these times
and like I don't know I was just
thinking about
how much the men in my life do for me
and it kind of not to say the women in
my life don't right I mean
but especially the guys like with men
it's just different when they help you
they never like women will throw back in
your face and say oh well I did for you
and they'll come back and just like list
all the things they did for you and like
it kind of takes like the genuineness of
it when you know you're mad at me
and you yell at me I mean I'm sure the
men have experiences I'm sure I've done
this you know I'm not even saying I'm
better